Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma-sambuddhassa
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed and noble self-awakened one.
So I just say this is our inaugural Full Moon Day meeting.
I've always wanted to do this, but I've never found a way to do it.
So I was really happy when Magda suggested that I try it on this medium.
So I think we can keep this going.
Luckily it's fallen on a Sunday and I'm inclined to in the future choose the closest Sunday to the full moon because that's most convenient for people.
In Sri Lanka they are public holidays, all the moons are public holidays so there's no problem in keeping the full moon itself there.
So my idea is that with every full moon we look at some of the teachings of the Buddha
and eventually throughout the year we cover it all.
So I'm going to start with this lovely little trilogy, a virtuous circle of gratitude, generosity and renunciation.
So starting with renunciation.
So the big problem here that can arise
is confusing what it is that we're actually renouncing so remember the body is not our fault when the body has appetite then it has appetite and when you put something uh lovely sweet on the on the tongue it will taste lovely and sweet that's never the problem as you know the problem is our relationship to it which is wanting more depending on it in order to establish a beautiful mental state
now that's what we've really got to grasp we use the sense bases not because they are just lovely in themselves but because they are a way of creating a lovely mental state hence you might have a piece of toast in the evening just to raise your spirits now the unfortunate thing of that of course is that you have dependency and that dependency is what we call attachment
and so there's a suffering there see if there's no bread and there's no toast well it's misery isn't it so when you uh when you when we click onto that we become much more sensitive to this draw towards what is pleasurable and uh this renunciation is therefore is not to be confused with well the word they use is self-mortification in other words blaming the body
for our mental states.
So that's an important distinction to make.
We're not trying to get rid of the pleasures and joys of life at all.
And the Buddha himself did enjoy life.
He enjoyed taste, but he didn't greed for it.
That's what it says in the scriptures.
this this whole uh idea of renunciation will arise on two different uh types of of grasping which is one about our wealth and the other about our time so we can be greedy with our time but not greedy with our wealth so we can be generous with our wealth but if somebody asks us to do something for them we shy off it and the other way around we can be very happy giving time but if somebody asks us for a bit of money
We're not inclined to give.
So, again, we have to look at that.
And this trilogy, this little virtuous circle of gratitude, generosity and renunciation, is not actually taught in the scriptures themselves as a way to liberation.
This is more a commentary pointed out.
And this, of course, of course, directly with our daily life.
This is our daily life, in our daily work, in the way we are with people.
So if we can generate that virtuous circle, it's actually drawing us towards liberation.
So letting go of attachment, letting go of dependency is the path to liberation.
So you might say that the whole of the path is one of renunciation.
Because eventually you've got to renounce the sense of self.
That's the last thing to go, this little idea that somewhere within us, we actually do believe ourselves to be this psychophysical organism, for want of a better word.
So that's this renunciation business.
Now, just to go to the front of the trilogy, this sense of gratitude.
Now, as you know, when you feel gratitude, it really is a heartwarming feeling, you know?
And when we feel this gratitude, we always want to repay it.
Now, if we spend some time just considering what we've received from our parents, our parents gave us our life, our mothers.
When you think about that, you might have problems with your mother and your father.
In fact, somebody once asked,
How do you know when you're fully liberated?
And they said, well, go and spend a week with your mother.
And then you'll know.
So it may be that our general relationship is a bit fractious and so on and so forth, but you still have your life through your parents.
And the Buddha said that even if you were to carry them,
on your shoulders the whole of your life you'd never repay them in fact it's unrepayable and that's what you begin to realize i think when you uh contemplate all everything that's been given to you you know from your family from your friends the good deeds and the companionship of family and friends all this is given to you and then there's uh things like
what society gives us, all our education.
You know, our parents could not have afforded, most of our parents could not have afforded to educate us.
And it's the same with the social services.
We might not have needed them up until now, but if we get old enough, you definitely begin to need them.
And of course, there's our health system.
You know, it's funny how you take something as a right
and you presume you just sort of presume that it's that it's something isn't given because either you've paid for it through the national insurance or because it's it's taken for granted but how many times have you thanked your doctors you know thank the dentist now the dentist i had here in bishops castle was really good uh the the front tooth here got finally gave in
and he put this false tooth in you know and and it was pretty awful you've got to get used to it you couldn't you couldn't eat nuts all the nuts got behind the tube behind the palate so you had to take it out and wash your mouth out and stick it back in and when i told him that it was it was a little uh inconvenient he finally decided to give me a bridge and there it is it's absolutely fantastic and it's a case of recognizing all these
uh gifts that people have given us if you bring to mind for instance the teachers one or two favorite teachers that you've had uh you know it does it does fill the heart with a sense of gratitude and finally of course there's there's nature you know just the earth that we live on which we become more and more aware of these days now what gratitude does is it makes you want to repay
And because you can't repay what has been given, you can't repay something that has been given to you freely.
You have to find a substitute.
And that draws you towards just being generous ourselves.
And that moves us into this whole area of generosity.
Now, when the Buddha talked to lay people, he always began with generosity.
He pointed out that even a thief can be generous.
He's just taken something off you and he's
He's very kindly given it to somebody in his family or friends.
So when we think about generosity, the ability to give without some idea of being repaid, and that's quite difficult for us.
So we have to clarify the mind about that.
Now, there are certain times you give gifts such as Christmas, which is more like a little ritual
re-establishing friendship you know so you get your pair of socks and and and they get their pair of socks and and that's fine unless of course the pair that they've given you is obviously much cheaper than what you spent on the socks that you gave them so that's when the trouble starts so so there's always a bit of bargaining going on it's always like a business like in business you see
so if we want to have an act of pure generosity then you have to listen to what's going on in the background of our minds about being repaid about being adored because of our generosity so if you're going to give for instance a donation to a charity and there are so many of them these days
you know you have to sort of get yourself into that mental state where that's that's the only thing in your mind and heart and you are giving this in order to help somebody right and there's no hope of repayment the charity is not going to give you any money back so so you're doing it for just that purpose and when you do it for that purpose that's when you act that's when you make the donation whether it's by card or by cash it doesn't really matter
and then of course once you've done it you'll hear these little voices you know like um you are truly a very wonderful person or you might you might get the one of that's too much what do you give so much for you could have so you have to be now you haven't been caught up in that you see so you've not been caught up in mara the mara did not catch you there so you can let those thoughts disappear and if guilt comes you have to point to it and say well that's that is false guilt because it
Because when I actually made the action, my heart was full of generosity.
And the same arises when you do something for somebody.
So I think most people, I certainly do, is say yes too quickly.
So if somebody says, you know, I've moved into this new house, it's actually happened to me.
I've moved into this new flat.
you know, and we're painting it, you know, would you like to, you know, come and give us a hand?
And I said, yeah, yeah, I'll come on Saturday, you see.
And then as I'm walking away, I'm thinking, what?
What have I given this Saturday away?
And in that case, at that time, I was, shall we say, advanced enough to actually make myself do it, to teach myself, not to say yes, you know, just because somebody asked something,
You don't have to say yes.
And there's a point where you can actually reflect for a moment and then say yes.
So it's coming from a point of reflection.
You're not just doing it by habit.
So again, that point of generosity, there has to be a certain reflection about it and that you are doing it from the heart of goodwill and that you're not even expecting a thank you.
And that's very difficult.
When I became a monastic, we're not supposed to say thank you.
I mean, I say it in the West because people get very upset.
But in the East, you're not supposed to, you don't say thank you.
You see, it undermines the person's gift.
That's the understanding.
Because if somebody gives something to you, they don't expect you to say thank you.
But if they expect you to say thank you, and then you don't say thank you, then of course, they feel very upset.
and that tells you that the gift is slightly corrupted they wanted praise they wanted appreciation so um to be able to give something without that desire to be acknowledged is is leading us towards a real uh pure heart generosity and the the uh the other little telltale is uh just to give that little bit more that pinches that little pinch
is where you're truly being generous, where you're giving just that bit of extra time, just that little bit of extra money.
And that's the point where it just begins to hurt a little bit.
That's the point where you are truly extending our generosity.
So just to recap, we have this lovely virtuous circle.
general this this feeling of gratitude and one exercise you can give yourself is just to say that tomorrow everything I will say thank you to everything I'll say thank thank you to the door that opens in Zen of course you always gassho when you enter a room you're always there you're taught to thank everything
you you have to gashow when you approach the table you gashow to the chair so this this whole attitude of actually not not presuming on anything not thinking that that we have a right to everything uh but that everything is a gift and if you go through the whole day like that you'd be surprised how it lifts you it really does lift you
And then once you've established more and more this sense of gratitude and the knowledge that you can't repay directly what people have given to you.
You have to find a way of expressing that gratitude through generosity.
And when we are being generous, just to stop for a moment and to make sure that you're doing it for pure reasons.
That's all.
And then to realize that when I've actually made an act of generosity with a pure heart, I've renounced something.
I've let go of something I'm holding on to.
And I'm actually practicing renunciation.
Letting go of that grip on things.
And that loosening of a grip, that letting go of these tight desires, wrong desires,
is a little every time we do that and we feel that that loss of grippiness that in a sense is a touch of libana because one of the descriptions of the of libana is is that it is desireless of these sorts of wrong desires so uh there's a lovely little practice there which you know is just ongoing
day in and day out and it's only a matter of reminding ourselves to do it and just very slowly it becomes a sort of a habitude that's all and really that's what we're doing in our practice we are just changing our habits moving away from habits which cause ourselves suffering and aren't very pleasant for others and moving towards habits which bring us happiness so there is
you know, the gift of the practice is a natural happiness in life.
It's not Nirvana, it's just a natural happiness.
And this happiness that we talk about is the internal environment, you know, within ourselves.
So this is a really powerful practice.
And I try and remember to do it myself occasionally.
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
that they have not caused even greater confusion and that you will, by your practice, become liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.